invité de sorgues a dit ce matin danely
francisque comédienne metteur en scène
auteur et co fondatrice de la compagnie
trac danely francisque bonjour
vous allez présenter à l'atrium les 19
et 20 janvier prochain la pièce la
diablesse femme sauvage et en marge de
cette pièce vous organisé demain à
partir de 18 heures toujours à l'atrium
une conférence débat sur la diablesse
mythe ou réalité
donc on parlera du magico religieux mais
aussi du rapport homme femme oui parce
que je en fouillant un petit peu le
sujet de la diablesse sujet qui me
fascine déjà depuis quelques années en
creusant un petit peu ça parle
effectivement d'une dune d'une femme
puissante une sorte de femmes puissantes
mais sans son homme il n'y a pas la
diablesse c'est à dire qu'elle existe
dans le désir des hommes donc la
diablesse a été inventé par les hommes
ben moi je m'interroge je me demande si
voilà ça ne serait pas une invention de
l'homme alors pourquoi pourquoi fois
alors ça c'est une grande question on
est là justement pour y réfléchir parce
que en fait là ne peut pas exister sans
l'autre et je me demande voilà en quoi
en quoi ce mythe à puce ancrée dans les
esprits la psyché martiniquaise qu'elle
soit féminine voilà ce qu dont ceux qui
ne savent pas la diablesse c'est quoi
alors la diablesse on dit que c'est une
femme séduisante une femme très très
belle qui porte un pied humain et un
sabot et qui se présente de façon
flamboyante dans des soirées dans des
ballots bord des routes au bord des
rivières elle est très belle et elle
s'est attirée elle sait séduire un homme
qui lorsqu'il lauzeral à suivre eh bien
on le retrouvera soit un peu plus grands
fous ou mort le lendemain et moi je me
suis interrogé qu'est ce qui se passe
entre les deux très bien alors votre
pièce la diablesse sera jouée je le
rappelle le disent les 19 et 20 janvier
à l'atrium et cette pièce mise en scène
du à l'amoureux au carnaval on y arrive
de exactement c'est vrai quand je suis
parti d'un personnage mythologique
caribéens et même au delà en fouillant
bien on se rend compte qu'il ya d'autres
figures de diablesse ailleurs dans le
monde et je me suis dit mais face à elle
qu'elle quel type d'homme je fais m pour
l'affronter et j'ai décidé d'y mettre un
homme si haut une sorte d'homme
séducteur qui voit là un chien forme qui
profitent du carnaval de cause attention
aux séductions en fonction contre
séduction mais lui ne sait pas qui il a
à faire elle elle sait voilà donc il va
s'en suivre un duel parce qu'il va se
rencontrer un moment qu'elle n'est pas
la proie mais que lui est la proie et il
va devoir se transcender trouver des
ressources en lui et se transformer pour
pouvoir se libérer kaltenhouse hauspie
ont alors créé pour créer les thèmes qui
m'inspire ce sont les thèmes qui me
touchent des sujets de fascination comme
la diablesse par exemple d'interrogation
des thèmes mystérieux comme elle l'est
et puis des thèmes de révolte aussi la
première fois que je suis monté sur
scène au théâtre c'était parler de
pourparlers de l'esclavagé parce que je
découvrais cette histoire j'étais sur
les bancs de l'université en france et
je me suis dit mais pourquoi j'ai mais
vraiment entendu parler de cette
histoire on n'a pas parlé sur les bancs
de l'école je ne comprends pas et j'ai
décidé d'en faire un spectacle
et puis par là même j'ai découvert un
peu mieux notre histoire et je les
partage et aussi avec le public parisien
est
l'autre sujet qui m'a amené à écrire
c'est c'est l'inceste avec lone cyclone
voilà qui a été créée en 2016 ici en
martinique et que nous avons présentés
ici devant un large public et est
récemment juillet 2010 est à avignon
d'accord justement vous avez joué cette
pièce avignon vous le dites vous le
disiez comment sont perçus nous oeuvre
comment sont perçus les pièces que l'on
exporte mais avec beaucoup de curiosité
je crois qu'il ya un public c'est à dire
quand on a en a une una on a une façon
d'aborder l'oeuvre artistique ou la
façon de la construire qui est qui est
très surprenante parfois pour les
personnes qui nous va de l'extérieur
alors pour cyclone en l'occurrence les
gens étaient un petit peu étonné de
cette atmosphère
déjà un cyclone bon et savent pas très
bien ce qu serre voilà c'est une c'est
une patte particulière une patte
caribéenne qui finalement interpelle
interroge et intéresse et puis on aborde
des sujets effectivement qu'ils sont qui
sont qui sont intéressants pour l'autre
l'autre bord on va dire est ce que le
est-ce que ce soit ça s'adresse comme
type de public si vous avez de tourner
uniquement des des compatriotes
ultramarins qui sont tus sont en
français alors les deux avignon c'est ça
brasse vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
monde donc on a on n'a pas rencontré
tout le public mais il y avait d un
public ultra marins mais également des
suisses voilà des gens de la région des
gens d'ailleurs on a eu quand même
beaucoup de spectateurs ça se passe le
pô le processus d'exportation êtes aidez
oui nous sommes aidés alors bien sûr on
him en nous on y mouille la chemise
aussi c'est à dire qu'il faut chercher
rendement qu'istres une femme orchestre
on peut dire ça même une femme de combat
on pourrait dire c'est à dire que bon
voila il s'agit de de se faire connaître
à l'extérieur et puis finalement de
vendre un produit est de savoir parler
du ce de cette oeuvre artistique qu'on
va leur proposer qui a qui est une
valeur ajoutée ou qui est qui a un
avantage comparatif qui avale acquis
spécificité et il faut trouver le bon
langage finalement pour convaincre et
puis nous sommes nous aider aussi
financièrement parce qu'effectivement le
ministère de la culture le ministère de
l'outre-mer me semble-t-il à un fonds
qui aide à l'exportation et la
circulation des oeuvres artistiques
alors la pièce cyclone a été jouée aussi
en martinique notamment d'un des pit oui
c'était 3-2 la volonté d'investir au
lieu autre que l'atrium il de se
rapprocher du public absolument oui
c'était il nous tenait à coeur alors
cette pièce là on l'a conçu ans qui a
été mise en scène par patrice le
namouric ont la conscience en circulaire
c'est à dire on est on imaginer un
public assis autour de ces deux femmes
qui s'affrontent encore un autre duel et
puis ben on a imaginé l'évidence c'était
de le jouer dans un pit qui est un lieu
de patrimoine donc ça nous permettait
également de réinvestir celui patrimoine
mais de façon différente et puis
finalement d'attirer un public qui n'a
pas l'habitude d'aller au théâtre et qui
surpris et curieux de découvrir un pitt
ou une pièce de théâtre dans un pit
sombre sont venues vraiment très
nombreux et ça a été ça a été vraiment
un moment unique et inoubliable
expérience se renouveler tout est
absolument absolument je pense que c'est
de ce sont des lieux alternatifs je
pense que qu'il nous revient aux six
artistes et compagnies de deux
d'imaginer
différemment nos diffusion des oeuvres
parce que en fait notre difficulté on a
une vraie vraie difficulté en martinique
pour diffuser les voilà il manque des
décès non on travaille pratiquement un
an pour créer un spectacle
pour une seule reprise en une seule
représentation voire 2 quand on a un peu
de chance bon ça fait beaucoup de
travail pour un une présentation très
courte finalement top et économiquement
c'est pas c'est pas rentable même dans
la rencontre avec le public on a envie
vraiment c'est un art du partage on a
envie vraiment de brasser le plus en de
plus le plus de monde possible
et puis sur sur la martinique c'est vrai
que tropiques atrium qui est une tête de
pont en termes de culture et de
diffusion artistique en martinique se
trouve à fort-de-france donc là les
diffusion artistique sont souvent
centralisée et on avait envie voilà je
trouve que c'est un très important de
pouvoir diffuser dans l'est dans les
communes et voilà qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire recenser toutes toutes
les salles possible est capable dada
d'accueillir des oeuvres d'accueillir du
théâtre oui oui le je pense que ce
recensement est déjà fait cesser hocine
je pense une vraie volonté politique une
politique culturelle engagé parce que je
crois vraiment que c'est indispensable
pour pouvoir offrir aux artistes
l'opportunité de 2,2 voilà de rencontrer
les publics parce que nous notre voilà
notre notre voeu c'est vraiment de
vibrer avec le public et de le
rencontrer au plus près et je crois
qu'il est important voire primordial et
même vital de concevoir une politique
culturelle qui nous qui permettent aux
artistes de diffuser leurs oeuvres dans
les communes alors vous parlais
justement de pro lutte politique
culturelle est-ce que selon vous vous
êtes revenu depuis 12 ans en martinique
est ce qu'il ya une véritable politique
culturelle en martinique je ne la sens
pas assez il doit y avoir une politique
culturelle mais je trouve qu'elle que ça
manque d'engagement je crois que ça va
de sa demande vraiment vraiment voilà
des vrais vrai engagement alors bien sûr
ça passe par le politique ça passe par
donc les élus ça passe aussi par les
communes ça passe par les artistes je
pense que ça passe vraiment par tous les
partenaires finalement delà de la
culture et de l'art crois qu'il y à il
ya quelque chose à faire alors je sais
qu'il ya des initiatives il ya des
initiatives qui ont été prises
à plusieurs reprises mais pour l'instant
je trouve que voilà ça ça manque encore
d'une dynamique réelle alors
est ce que les politiques ont perçu
alors manque de dynamique réelle
les politiques n'ont pas perçu que cela
pouvait être un moteur de développement
économique je crois qu'il faut encore
les convaincre oui je crois que je crois
que il faut qu'ils se rendent compte que
la favorisent le lien social c'est
vraiment rencontré des gens les amener à
les amener à rêver à se positionner à se
projeter à etc voilà apporter ce sont
des comme disait aimé césaire des armes
miraculeuses finalement qui permettent
aux qui permettent le développement
spirituel
intellectuel social humain est bien sûr
un développement économique bien sûr
évidemment il ya ya ya de quoi aussi
aller en mai de l'exportation aussi de
l'image de la main exactement il ya de
quoi valoriser vraiment on a déjà
renforcé notre patrimoine artistique
vivant contemporain et en plus aussi
exporter cette image notamment par le
cinéma qui permet vraiment de 2,2
d'envoyer très loin nos images et de et
de l'image de la martinique la
promouvoir le cinéma justement une
toujours pas de but au tournage mais
malheureusement je dirais mais jacques
tri sens oui je suis aussi actrice je
crois que c'est très important de de
bien saisir l'importance et l'enjeu que
représente ce bureau de tournage
non seulement pour faire travailler les
artistes acteurs techniciens du cinéma
et de l'audiovisuel en martinique mais
aussi lorsque ces images sont tournées
d'un valoriser vraiment le lac la
qualité la qualité des images
cinématographiques martiniquaise ici et
ailleurs est très très loin vous avez
reçu un certain nombre de pris à
l'extérieur c'est important aussi de
cette reconnaissance m'écouter j'étais
la première surprise mais je crois que
c'est important parce que finalement ces
prix là vienne vienne saluer un parcours
l'ordre à paris métrage gueule oui c'est
à dire c'est un court métrage qui
s'appelle tourment d'amour tournée en
sainte dans une petite île de la caraïbe
et qui finalement circulent aux états
unis en inde à berlin à barcelone et
c'est effectivement et surtout ce
parcours là j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
d'avoir reçu des prix d'interprétation
daniela france-italie
[Musique]
dernier livre quand c'est ce que je vous
remercie bonne journée aller coûte de
nos programmes merci beaucoup